what lies beneath the dark subconscious
of a faceless silent killer what is
present behind the black eyes of what
was just a six-year-old child on
halloween night in 1963. one psychiatric
doctor by the name of samuel loomis was
prepared to find out what goes bump in
the night within the mind of haddonfield
illinois boogeyman and michael myers to
learn the fate of dr loomis's fiancee
and how it might have changed his entire
life going forward stick around to the
end of this video
[Music]
welcome to horror history in today's
lesson i am analyzing the man who tried
to understand an incomprehensible evil
there are many versions of this
character because there are many
alternate timelines in the halloween
story i like to think of the timeline
like a train map the halloween express
today i'll just be analyzing the
original timeline where dr loomis is
portrayed by actor donald pleasance
there may be other videos where we ride
the halloween express down alternate
routes if you want to make things more
complicated there is a theory that the
character sam loomis in psycho is the
very same sam loomis as the one in the
halloween series sam loomis in psycho
follows a private investigator to find
his missing girlfriend marion crane but
before sam can find her she's already
dead alongside the private investigator
this theory says that sam was driven to
the obsession of learning how the
criminal mind works which leads him to
take the job at smith's grove sanitarium
where he meets michael as much fun as
that idea is personally i think
halloween sam loomis was just named
after psycho sam loomis because director
john carpenter was paying homage to a
great movie that inspired the slasher
genre in order for me to turn dr
loomis's psychoanalysis back at him i'm
going to take it back to his first
appearance in the franchise
dr samuel loomis began his psychological
studies of the feared michael myers on
november 5th 1963 when michael was
admitted to smith's grove sanitarium
michael was silent and unmoving after
the murder of his sister judith myers dr
louis seemed to think that he was
experiencing severe trauma and damage to
his psychological health he opted for
specialized treatment to try to
penetrate through michael's unwavering
lack of emotional response the early
months of loomis's care for michael are
mostly a mystery because this time
period is never covered in the halloween
canon however if we look at the
non-canon chaos comics material we can
get a little bit more backstory this is
one of those cases where the comic
doesn't contradict anything in the
movies and it can potentially help us
understand loomis a little bit better so
i'm kind of okay with talking about it
as long as we remember that this
technically doesn't count loomis
requested his supervisor dr carpenter to
move michael into a private room safely
away from the other juveniles of the
building but dr carpenter declined
loomis request and kept michael where he
was with the other juveniles there was
one other doctor at the sanitarium that
saw michael the same way that loomis did
a woman by the name of jennifer hill he
asked her to speak with dr carpenter
with him in order to convince him that
michael needed to be moved dr hill did
agree to do this under the condition
that loomis take her out to dinner and
although their attempt to get michael
move to solitary was not successful dr
hill's attempt at romance was and the
two started dating bonding over their
shared beliefs about psychotherapy over
the next few months a few incidents took
place with the other juveniles at the
facility like michael shoving a crayon
deep into the fellow patient tony
o'malley's left eye this was before
security cameras were common so loomis
and the smith's grove staff could not
find any evidence that michael was
responsible and ended up blaming another
child in november a child by the name of
adrian wade ate an entire birthday cake
that was supposed to be given to michael
shortly after adrian was found in the
shower room with second-degree burns all
over his body he later died in the
hospital of heart failure after months
of further study of michael and his
psychological health dr loomis started
to believe that the young myers boy did
not suffer from trauma that occurred on
halloween 1963 but found that behind his
eyes leaked only darkness he had no
conscience no remorse no response to the
perception of life death consequence or
right and wrong only a psyche of pure
evil
i spent eight years trying to reach him
and then another seven trying to keep
him locked up because i realized that
what was living behind that boy's eyes
was purely and simply
evil on may 1 1964 only months after
michael was admitted to smith's grove
sanitarium loomis met with two of the
lead doctors the facility to try to move
michael to a maximum security ward in
litchfield illinois the two doctors
refused loomis's suggestion stating that
michael was in a state of comatose and
did not react to anything in his
surroundings but loomis did not agree
loomis believed that michael was using
the state of mind to cover up his true
dark behaviors and insisted he be moved
somewhere else where it would be
impossible for him to escape the doctors
then gave loomis a choice either loomis
would continue working with michael at
smith's grove or someone else would be
assigned to the patient loomis
reluctantly agreed to the doctor's terms
because he felt that no one else could
be trusted to work with him it makes me
wonder if things could have gone
differently if another doctor had worked
closely with michael it seems like one
of the main issues was that most of the
other doctors didn't believe that such a
young boy could be so full of evil so it
might have benefited loomis to have
someone else see the patient from his
perspective the only one who really kind
of understood the danger that michael
posed was his girlfriend dr hill as the
two continued to get closer they were
eventually engaged with a wedding
planned for december 1971. however
disaster would strike before the big day
would come in october 1971 dr carpenter
threw a halloween party at the
sanitarium which loomis was heavily in
opposition of that night the electricity
went out and a girl by the name of nancy
was found dead drowned during a game of
bobbing for apples the same night dr
hill was found dead outside of the
sanitarium her death was ruled a suicide
because it seemed that she either fell
out or jumped off the roof of the
building but loomis knew better he knew
in his gut that jennifer would not kill
herself and he couldn't see a scenario
that didn't involve michael getting his
hands dirty i think this was really the
last straw for him jennifer was the one
person that loomis could connect to not
only in terms of his personal life but
also at work she was the only other
person who could see michael's true
nature i think this must be when he
snapped and made it his life's goal to
suppress the evil lurking inside of the
sanitarium for the next seven years he
did his best to keep michael locked away
from society and this strategy worked
until the night of october 30th 1978
where michael escaped from captivity to
bring evil upon hattenfield once again
[Music]
[Applause]
loomis and his assistant nurse marion
chambers were given the assignment of
transporting michael from smith's group
sanitarium to his home county of
livingston for trial the week prior
michael had turned 21 and was due in
court to see if he was fit to be
released on the drive up to smith's
grove loomis continually refers to
michael as it which marian catches on to
don't you think we could refer to it as
him
if you say
here loomis shows that he no longer sees
michael as a human but as an embodiment
of pure evil he suggests that marion
should give michael a dose of thorazine
which is a strong drug used to control
psychotic disorders causing her to
realize that loomis doesn't want michael
to have any chance of winning his trial
as they get closer to the facility they
notice several of the patients wandering
the grounds which strikes dread into him
because he fears that michael may have
escaped he runs up to the gates to use
the telephone trying to warn the staff
when michael jumps on the roof of the
car and grabs marion through the window
loomis is unable to stop michael as he
chases marion out of the car gets inside
and frantically drives away strangely
loomis doesn't seem that shocked at
michael's ability to operate a car even
though he'd been locked up since age six
and probably had never even been in a
car over the last 15 years his response
all ties back to the idea that michael
is no man but rather just an incarnation
of evil itself we're just seeing how
desensitized he has become to it in fact
he already knows michael is on his way
back to haddonfield for halloween and
drives in that direction on his way he
discovers michael's medical gown and the
matchbook that marion had used the night
before so he knows he's on the right
track he decides to investigate the
gravesite of judith myers only to find
her headstone has been removed
confirming his suspicion that michael
has come home after enlisting the help
of the local sheriff lee bracket the two
check out michael's old residence at 45
lamkin lane which has been broken into
the two discover michael's first
confirmed victim of the evening a dog
they found in the house see i can kind
of disagree but sympathize with michael
wanting to take out humans but a dog
that's just messed up man loomis
convinces sheriff bracket that michael
is probably nearby and needs to be
captured it's here that we see that
despite his bravery to try to spot
michael loomis is terrified of
haddenfield's so-called boogeyman and
the capabilities that he possesses
loomis eventually discovers the stolen
sanitarium vehicle from the night before
across the street he walks the streets
of haddonfield until later that evening
he sees two young kids running out of a
house screaming loomis is able to
recognize their screams as true terror
as opposed to an innocent halloween
prank
[Music]
and he runs into the house to find 17
year old lori strode being strangled by
michael laurie manages to pull michael's
mask off for a moment giving loomis time
to shoot him how many times dr loomis i
shot him six times which sends michael
over the balcony railing onto the lawn
by the time loomis tends to lori and
looks over the balcony his former
patient is no longer there michael had
vanished and we can visibly see how
shaken up dr loomis is by the
realization that his nemesis isn't just
evil inhuman and possibly the devil
incarnates but also invincible loomis
looks out into the world wondering where
michael has gone next the next door
neighbor comes out and helps loomis get
a hold of the police so the search
continues leading to this incident
[Music]
[Applause]
sheriff bracket asks if this victim is
michael but before they find out bracket
is informed that his teenage daughter
annie was found dead sheriff brackett
identified the body and set off to tell
his wife of the circumstances which he
blames on luminous that's gotta be
crushing for dr loomis he tried to warn
the psychiatric hospital how dangerous
michael was for 15 years then he got
away dr looms his worst nightmares came
true despite his best efforts and after
all of that he still shoulders the brunt
of the blame that kind of treatment just
makes a guy go
deputy hunt would fill in for bracket
from that point forward hunt believes
that the crash victim is michael which
may have just been wishful thinking
because loomis is not convinced the
dentist at the coroner's office
estimated the burned body from his teeth
to be about 17 years old although a full
check of dental records would take hours
to complete i think some part of loomis
knows that michael is still on the loose
so he convinced deputy hunts to a
further patrol of the town loomis
directs him back to the myers house
thinking that maybe if michael is
injured the familiarity of his old home
could give him security in his
vulnerable states the house is already
being swept by police while local
townsfolk mob outside and vandalize the
place as some kind of weird post-tragedy
form of protest it's there that a pair
of high school boys expressed concern to
deputy hunt because their friend bennett
tramer didn't get home after leaving a
costume party hunt and loomis both
suspect the worst that the burned body
belonged to traemer meaning that myers
must still be out there before being
able to really put together a plan
they're called to hattonfield elementary
school where another break-in has taken
place possibly their chance to catch
michael they discover a child's picture
of a family decorated with a knife that
michael is left piercing the daughter's
heart on the chalkboard the word samhain
is written in red and lumis is the only
one that knows its celtic origins it's
essentially an ancient gaelic festival
of the dead celebrating the end of
summer and the beginning of winter which
began on what we now know is halloween
night they're interrupted by nurse
chambers who informs dr loomis that the
governor has ordered him to leave
haddonfield under the belief that he's
contributing to the hysteria loomis at
first refuses he desperately wants to
find and stop michael this is where we
really see his behavior cross over from
concerned into obsessive michael myers
had essentially become his life's work
and he didn't have anything or anyone
else to go back to he was ready to try
to stop michael no matter the cause
however there was already a state
marshal waiting outside so loomis had no
choice but to be escorted by him and
marion i mean i never understood why he
doesn't just try to sneak out the back i
guess he just knows that medicine is his
thing and stealth is not however once in
the police car he learns of a secret
government sealed document which would
change everything he thought he knew
about michael's rampage
[Music]
on the car ride back into smith's grove
marion drops this bomb on dr loons
there's a file on michael myers that
nobody knew about i've seen everything
no it was hidden sealed by the court
after his parents were killed
now after the governor heard what
happened tonight he authorized dr rogers
to open it
that girl that strode girl that's
michael meyer's sister loomis has the
revelation that michael is in hatton
field to finish what he started 15 years
ago by taking out the other sister so he
pleads with the marshall to take him to
the hospital where lori is being kept
but to no avail so in a fit of
desperation he grabs his revolver and to
show that he's serious fires a shot
through the passenger window and demands
to be taken to the hospital you can't
just do that i mean where does he think
he is la county loomis desperation is
starting to get the better of him by
threatening an officer of the law at
gunpoint he's basically declaring that
he'll try to stop the boogeyman of
haddenfield even if it means destroying
himself dr samuel loomis turned from a
by the book concerned psychiatrist to a
man overcome with obsession i might
normally compare his behavior against a
medically recognized disorder as i have
for some other characters that i've
analyzed but as far as i can tell he
doesn't really have a disorder he's just
obsessed with stopping michael and given
what he's been through it's not
impossible to blame him i think about
every group project ever loomis has
tried to convince others and work with
others to prevent a disaster but
eventually they all let him down and
he's gotta do it himself even if this
leads him down a dark road of aggression
and even committing crimes it's probably
a good thing too because he arrives at
haddonfield hospital just in time to
save lori from michael's rat the state
marshal is not so lucky
i guess loomis is off the hook but also
no because he's once again face to face
with michael and michael is invincible
he and laurie run to try to take cover
in an operating room but michael easily
tears through the door and stabs his
doctor in the stomach before turning his
rage against lori who managed to get a
hold of loomis's revolver and shoot
michael in the eyes to temporarily blind
him meanwhile loomis realizes it's gonna
take something more than bullets or like
a cleverly placed trail of reese's
pieces to stop michael and devises a
plan to trap him by opening the
compressed gas canisters in the room
before saying this
[Music]
and after giving lori a moment to run
for it he lights the place up
potentially sacrificing himself to put a
stop to the evil that inhabits the mind
of his patients on the morning of
november 1st the ambos roll that means
ambulances came my mom heard it on a
medical show once and thought it was
hilarious so i'm just going to go with
it somehow by some miracle dr sam loomis
survived the massive explosion at
haddonfield hospital and the seemingly
fatal stab to his abdomen he would live
on with major burn scars on his face and
walk with a limp needing to use a cane
for the rest of his life not too bad for
being blown up as a 60 year old man
right those must have been some real
fast ambos however as expected michael
isn't entirely out of the picture yet
either but he does go into a coma
allowing him to be captured and placed
back into a psychiatric facility despite
michael spending the next 10 years in a
coma loomis is still obsessed and still
fears the evil that lurks within him his
new life's work is to prevent anyone
from living through the halloween night
that he and laurie escaped as more time
passes michael is seen as less and less
of a threat by his peers only he and
lori know that one day michael will rise
again and then it's just him because
lori passes away in 1987 leaving behind
a daughter named jaime a year after her
death loomis is still fighting just as
hard to keep michael locked up the staff
actually go behind his back to transfer
michael from the high security facility
he's at ridgemont federal sanitarium
back to smith's grove on october 30th
1988. loomis immediately goes into
object when he finds out and to his
horror learns of an accident that
occurred during the patient transforms
without another word he storms out of
the room to find his patient once again
and prevent a repeat of what happened 10
years earlier to this day this time he
suspects michael will be coming after
lori strode's daughter jaime loy the
closest living relative when loomis sees
the accident site he's not too convinced
that it was an accident and heads back
to haddonfield for another round of
serial killer hide and seek hide and
seek are we really gonna play that
no not you go away loomis stops at a gas
station but upon further investigation
he finds more than he was expecting for
one if you thought loomis was obsessed
with michael and get a load of this gas
station diner owner i think he's even
more obsessed with regular abraham
lincoln loomis finds the owner tied up
in metal chains and some women on the
floor who also bit the dust he tries to
dial out for help but to his surprise
all of the phones had been broken to be
fair michael's not going to use him he
doesn't talk but the biggest surprise
for loomis is behind him
no i mean the other direction he turns
and finds michael standing in the
kitchen just staring at him loomis
pleads with him not to return to hatton
fields if you want another victim take
me
but leave those people in peace with no
response loomis shoots off four rounds
from his gun but it's no good michael
vanishes loomis runs outside to find him
when a truck smashes through the garage
doors loomis shoots off four more rounds
to no avail michael intentionally
sideswipes the gas pump and the
explosion blows up loomis's car in the
process i always love how if you look
closely at the car it just jumps off the
ground
dr sam probably didn't find it so funny
though he is now stranded without a way
of catching up to michael and the hell
that he's about to unleash on
haddonfield loomis walks down the lonely
road and after being punked by some kids
is picked up by reverend jackson sayer
who tells him that you can't kill evil
they don't die like a man dies lumis
understands this all too well he's been
living with the consequences of that
since 1978. sayer drops him at the
haddonfield police station and he warns
the new sheriff ben meeker just like
practically everyone meeker doesn't
believe him at first imagine if people
just listen to doctors when they warn
about dangerous things after some debate
the sheriff reluctantly declares a state
of emergency and all of haddonfield's
citizens are told to lock down inside of
their homes imagine if they actually
listened dr loomis probably thinks about
michael's attack pattern 10 years ago to
make his next move in 78 michael went to
his childhood home to try to find his
sister lori so this time loomis suspects
that he'll go to the adoptive home of
his niece jaime there he finds pictures
of lori scattered on the floor and the
family dog loomis is too late but he
does learn that michael is indeed
repeating his 1978 rampage loomis and
maker search the town and find jaime
trick-or-treating with her adoptive
sister rachel they're picked up and put
in the squad car but find themselves
immediately surrounded by the very thing
they were supposed to be protected from
after discovering that some pranksters
in town were doing a little michael
myers cosplay and nearly shooting them
loomis and sheriff maker returned to the
police station to find it completely
destroyed with michael also having
demoted one of the deputies to halloween
decoration if you know what i mean a
good old group of illinois boys show up
at the police station demanding to know
what was going on in haddonfield loomis
tells them that michael has returned
which meeker isn't happy with claiming
that he just created a lynch mob however
loomis seems undisturbed by this
accusation you haven't got a police
force
these men may be the only defense you've
got being the only adult alive that has
witnessed the sheer horror that is
michael it seems that he's willing to
just take whatever help he can get he
obviously did not realize that cops do
it by the book i have no idea what that
means still they bring jaime and rachel
to the only safe place they have left
sheriff meeker's home where with the
help of deputy logan they armed
themselves and board the place up
satisfied with jaime's safety loomis
goes back on the offensive and tries to
return to jaime's house to find michael
he doesn't find him but he does later
that night run back into jaime as she is
running from him and decides to take her
to the schoolhouse for safety the school
may have actually been considered safe
back then i don't know but i guess this
school would be considered an exception
because michael is already there waiting
for them and throws loomis through a
glass door
loomis is pretty metal i mean he's been
stabbed blown up and now thrown through
a door seems like he's just as hard to
kill as michael is loomis is present
later on when the police and the
illinois boys all shoot michael down at
once sending him into a well and
interestingly he seems to believe that
michael is actually dead this time
despite years of evidence that michael's
death is simply not a possibility
michael myers is in hell
buried
where he belongs it seems out of
character for loomis to be that naive
doesn't it my take is that he was about
70 at this point and he probably didn't
think he'd be around if michael came
back after another 10 years or so almost
like he needed to believe that michael
was dead so he could die in peace
obviously the real reason is that
director dwight little didn't really
want to make another halloween movie but
this is a video about loomis not dwight
little
[Music]
dr loomis returns home with jamie and
her family to help them settle back in
but after hearing a chilling scream
loomis rushes to the stairway to find a
jaime holding a pair of scissors loomis
cannot believe what he sees the evil he
spent the last 25 years trying to
vanquish is now logged into the body of
the one girl that he was able to save to
put this in perspective this is like
playing a whole game but then your file
gets deleted at 99 percent loomis's
psyche begins to break the terror of the
idea that the evil had just latched on
to another soul is too much for him to
bear and he raises his gun to shoot but
not before being stopped by sheriff
maker however the circumstances are not
quite as bad as they first seemed over
the next year jaime seems to get control
of the evil connection she now has she
is now the newest patient of dr loomis
but she doesn't become an empty soulless
shape like michael had she does however
go mute due to the trauma of the year
before and suffers from what seems to be
terrors and seizures in the night but
lewis seems to know that there's more to
it than that for his own sake it's
probably a good thing that he's able to
work with jaime because he now has
something to live for again but because
he's so jaded now it often comes off as
kind of scary for her loomis comes and
checks on jamie one day during her stay
at the facility while rachel and her
friends tina are visiting a brick
smashes through the window with a note
attached reading the evil child must die
loomis believes the people of
haddenfield are afraid of jaime because
they think that she's following in
michael's footsteps on october 31 1989
one year into his care for her jaime
drew something that caught loomis's
attention a horrific drawing of the
family dog max i would not want to be a
dog in hattenfield in late october
loomis called the families home to check
on max because he had discovered that
jaime could sense things he aggressively
demanded that she write down whatever
she knew
right right right
for me this is the point of no return
for lunus he has good intentions but he
doesn't treat jaime with the same
patience that he gave michael early on
jaime soon suffers another seizure which
convinces loomis that she's mentally
linked to michael he tells sheriff maker
about how he believes that michael is
still alive
but the sheriff is called away to the
cemetery and so loomis returns to try to
get more answers out of jaime
[Music]
what about your stepmother jamie harry
harry did you put your name in the
goblet of fire he then tells jaime of
his trip to the cemetery where
supposedly someone had dug up the coffin
of a nine-year-old girl
what do you think he's going to do with
that whoa man he also tries searching
the myers house again but honestly what
is he going to do to him at this point
he shot him several times blew him up
loaded him with bullets again and yet
michael still lives on for these reasons
i don't think he was there to find
michael i think he was there to set a
trap which would come into play later
that's halloween night
dr loomis decides to stay by jaime's
side that evening as she attends her
school's costume party it's here that
she has another vision thanks to her
connection with her uncle which helps
them figure out that tina williams was
in danger near dale's gas station across
town and loomis gets sheriff meeker on
the phone to help save her tina returns
to the clinic to comfort jaime for a
short period of time but decides to
attend a halloween party later that
evening loomis begs her to stay thinking
that she's still gonna be in danger but
tina doesn't believe him and blames him
for filling jaime's head with all of
these boogeyman stories the interaction
shows that he's become seen by the
younger people in town is more of a
crazy old man than an experienced
michael myers veteran and survivor
loomis instructs the local police to
follow her however jaime sees that tina
is going to be in danger again and
sneaks out to try to warn her herself
jamie's not in her room she's nowhere in
sight
[Music]
thomas
what the hell are you doing my thoughts
exactly the guy is just out of control
however he still keeps finding ways to
be helpful as he helps the police find
jaime who had escaped with her classmate
billy hill near an old barn they were
not in time to save tina but jaime and
billy are escorted to safety jaime is
gaining some of her voice back and she
asks if loomis will be able to kill
michael to which he replies
for some reason even though nothing in
this 26 year span should lead him to
believe that michael is mortal on the
bright side for them this causes jaime
to agree to help loomis and the police
by using her visions to help locate and
catch michael as the ambos and police
officers leave the scene loomis
approaches the edge of the forest and
yells into the trees at michael claiming
that his rage will destroy him someday
that killing everyone will not make it
go away he instructs michael to go home
or loomis and jaime will be waiting for
him sure enough they set up jaime and
judas old room as the police surround
the house and wait for haddenfield's
silent killer to approach loomis is
waiting in the hall when he's called
into the room because jaime's having
another one of her psychic connection
episodes this time it appears that billy
is the one in danger though i guess you
could argue that this was all a
diversion based on what happens next
lumis radios the sheriff and tells him
that michael is at the children's clinic
so meeker sends all of his officers
there leaving the outside of the house
unguarded it seems like this was looms
plan all along it could be that he
figures michael will not show up if the
police are all around or maybe he
thought that with fewer people there
will be fewer casualties plus this kind
of allows him to operate the way that he
wants to which as we'll see shortly is
probably not something that anyone on
the police force would have approved of
he tells the one remaining officer to
stay with jaime as he descends towards
the main level of the house where
michael is coming in and they meet face
to face once again knowing he's here for
jaime loomis informs him that he
believes jaime can stop the rage inside
of him he reminds him of how he used to
be before the rage engulfed him he's
trying to break through to michael on a
more human level a side of him that the
doctor had long thought to be dead why
does he suddenly think he can reach some
semblance of humanity buried inside of
his former patients it's because of
jaime jaime was supposedly overcome by
the same evil that affected michael but
she was able to overcome it and go back
to being a good person he tries to take
michael's knife away from him gently
until michael cuts him across the
stomach and throws him through a railing
[Music]
michael follows the sound of jamie and
the officer upstairs trying to escape
and after jaime is almost killed by
michael about a hundred times she runs
back downstairs and finds loomis there
to comfort her but things take a turn
for the worse instead of running away
like normal people loomis decides to
lure and taunt michael with jaime using
her as bait at the end of the stairs
this is almost definitely the worst
thing that he's ever done because
judging by her reaction jaime had no
idea that she was going to be used as
bait like this in such a close encounter
with her mass stalker this is the face
of the clinically insane
if you see this man do not engage him
let's play a game yep he is officially
crossed into jigsaw territory now
okay so he's not actually giving her up
to him at least i guess that's slightly
redeeming when michael reaches the
middle of the room loomis pulls a rope
releasing a nap made with heavy chains
he also loads him up with darts from a
tranquilizer gun and in a moment of
madness just savagely beats him with
this wooden board
not sure that's gonna do a lot but it
probably felt good i know where i was
for a minute
felt good though the police show up in
place michael and holding which is
glossed over but it's a huge milestone
for loomis people are finally seeing
michael the way that he sees him and
they're willing to put him in an actual
jail rather than dumping him in another
psychiatric facility the plan is to
transfer him to a maximum security
facility where he would stay until death
or in his case just forever
unfortunately for haddenfield and its
police force forever ends up not even
being more than a night because a
mysterious character in a black trench
coat shows up takes out the entire
police station and frees michael myers i
compared dr loomis to jigsaw earlier so
i guess this guy is hoffman game over
michael was free to exercise his
immortality against the people of
haddenfield once more but dr loomis's
health would finally get the better of
him as he suffered a stroke not long
after
[Music]
imagine that halloween in 1989 was the
biggest roller coaster that samuel
loomis ever went through he had finally
found michael captured him only for him
to be released by another powerful
evil-doer based on the information we
have loomis suffered his stroke sometime
after this but i like to imagine that it
was the same night right when he found
out that michael had escaped his brain
basically freaked out and he ends up
realizing that he can't go on like this
anymore for the better of his health he
retired from his position at smith's
grove sanitarium and moved to a secluded
lifestyle in a cabin in rural illinois
he also got surgery to remove the burn
scars from his face everything was
peaceful for the next six years until he
got a visit from an old friend on
october 30th 1995. his old boss dr
terence winn comes in to see him on that
dark rainy night wind had come to
celebrate his own retirement and wants
to convince loomis to go back as chief
administrator of smith's grove it's
during this discussion that loomis
recognizes a familiar voice on the radio
calling for hell that voice belongs to
jaime now 15 years old and her body is
discovered mutilated the next morning
halloween 1995. loomis knows that the
nightmare has returned and michael myers
was back for round six despite the fact
that he's already on borrowed time and
being in his mid-70s and having endured
a handful of life-threatening scenarios
he just can't turn a cold shoulder to
the city of haddenfield even now they
still don't seem to have any respect for
him despite all he's been through for
them it's been quiet here for six years
and that's the way it's gonna stay
and the last thing i need now is you
going around spouting off ghost stories
lumis quickly retorts that michael myers
is his business he's now a part of the
legend of michael myers the town's
people almost see him as synonymous with
michael as if he's some kind of warning
sign that the boogeyman is back loomis
and win go to the hospital to visit
jaime when he's approached by an even
older familiar face this is tommy doyle
the little boy that laurie strode was
babysitting on that fateful halloween
night in 1978. tommy starts to tell him
about other relatives in the strode
family that are now living in michael's
old house but he's rushed out of the
hospital by security before he can tell
the whole story tommy tells him to meet
him at the campus rally at 9 that night
and loomis knows that he'll have to
prepare himself to face his old patient
one last time as per tradition he pays a
visit to michael's old house but its new
residents aren't home when he arrives so
he just makes like a video game
character and lets himself inside
eventually he meets the strode matriarch
deborah strode and warns her of his
suspicion of michael's immediate return
he urges her and her family to
immediately leave town when he gets back
to the hospital he learns that jaime was
off the previous night he confronts
jaime's doctor outrage and in a great
amount of pain because of jaime's
passing remember jaime was essentially
dr loomis's greatest work he was able to
save her from becoming the next michael
myers the conversation does yield an
interesting piece of information though
if there's some kind of law about
sharing a patient's medical information
the doctor ignores it and reveals that
he found placental fluids in jaime's
body meaning she had given birth about
24 hours before only they did not know
where the baby was loomis on the other
hand thinks he does he meets tommy at
the campus rally looking to talk further
but first they discover another myers
casualty this time the body of radio
personality buries sins loomis and tommy
returned to the boarding house that
tommy's staying at across the street
from the old meyer's house but they
discovered that the baby which tommy is
named steven is now missing there were
also two other strodes taking cover in
tommy's room strode and her son dany
these are the adoptive cousins of lori
strode and they are also now missing but
they're soon discovered when michael
chases them to the front door and tommy
lets them in tommy asks loomis who else
knew about the baby stephen which leads
him to having a big
realization
plus knew i had the baby no one no
there had to be someone else who knew
nobody knew it except me
they turned to the living room and see
danny sitting on the lap of the
mysterious black trench coat man who
helped free michael in 1989 who turns
out to be none other than the retiring
smith's grove administrator and dr
terrance wynne loomis discovers that
wynn is part of an organization called
the cult of thorn who worships the demon
thorne the same evil that possessed
michael myers since 1963 and cannot
leave his body until he kills the last
remaining member of michael's family
this explains michael's entire life
since that first dreaded halloween which
was now 32 years ago dr loomis takes
tommy doyle back to smith's grove one
last time and asked tommy to wait in the
hall as he confronts wynn who invites
him to join the cult of thorn loomis
isn't having any of that though and is
prepared to shoot dr wynn but one of the
cult members sneaks up on him and knocks
him out
he wakes up around the time that tommy
has rescued kara stephen and danny
strode and helps them get away from
michael by shooting the controls for the
door and hailing an elevator for cara
and the kids tommy catches up with them
and invites loomis to flee the hospital
with them but loomis's decision goes
back to the decision he made when all of
this cult of thorn business began he was
happily retired when he discovered
michael's return in 1995 and he made the
decision to come back to haddenfield to
try to stop michael one last time he
knew he didn't have much gas left in the
tank and he was never planning on
walking away with his own life we never
see exactly what his fate is but his
story ends on this shot where michael
has shed his mask on the floor next to a
syringe and we hear loomis cry out one
final time before his story ends
i've always interpreted this ending to
mean that loomis eventually lost his
life doing what he dedicated it to
trying to hunt down his most infamous
psychiatric patient technically speaking
it's a very ambiguous ending you could
say that both of their fates at the end
of this timeline will always be unknown
the reason for my interpretation has
more to do with the context behind it
the original ending known as the
producer's cut shows loomis going back
to smith's grove and discovering what he
thinks is michael but turns out to be dr
nguyen with the iconic michael myers
mask placed over his face leaving the
story open for another chapter but sadly
the actor donald pleasance passed away
shortly after filming so the ending was
reworked for the theatrical cut which is
technically canon and gives us more of a
proper conclusion to loomis's story we
see dr samuel loomis turned from a
clinical psychologist treating mentally
distressed children to a man obsessed
with the destruction of one of his
patients while that doesn't sound like
the most noble of characters on the
surface when you break him down you
discover that he puts the care of others
first in his heart and even before
himself he's a selfless man giving his
time and his energy to protect the town
of haddonfield and the strode family
line and he continues to do so even
though none of the people he saves end
up respecting him his later years were
corrupted by his growing obsession with
stopping his adversary which only
worsened his reputation but he kept on
fighting right down to the very end let
me know in the comments what halloween
character you'd like to see me cover
next on horror history there are a ton
of options for example the rob zombie
timeline version of dr loomis is a
different character that i could analyze
that leaves us with like four lorries
four michaels and probably two or three
tommy's we could be at this for a while
so let me know who you really want to
see you'll find all of those videos in
the playlist on the left remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]